Okay, good morning. So, today we do the
scientific revolution, okay? And as I
mentioned
in previous classes,
it was really Dante
who helped give the give birth to the
idea of modernity. And he really
launched three major movements, which
include the Renaissance, the Protestant
Reformation, and the scientific
revolution, okay? We would not have
modernity without
Dante.
Okay.
All right. So, let's see how the three
connect together, okay? We're going to
review
the previous two classes to connect to
today's class on the scientific
revolution. So, the Renaissance, what it
was was it was a celebration of what
makes us human.
Before we were focused on the divine,
on the idea of God. Now, we want to tell
the story of what it means to be human,
okay? That's the Renaissance.
Protestantism believes that we have
direct access to God.
The Catholic religion,
the Pope is the divine representative,
and the clergy is the
spokesperson for
for God. But Protestant Protestant
believes that we have direct access to
God, we should be able to speak with God
directly through the Bible.
Um
The scientific revolution, it's really
about how can we know God,
okay? That's the idea of the scientific
revolution. So,
let's review why we have these ideas.
And it has to do with Dante. So,
remember last week we discussed the
dialogue between Beatrice and Dante.
Let's review it really quickly. So,
Beatrice is saying,
I just said that
God is perfect. Whatever God touches,
whatever God creates is perfect. So, if
that's the case, why is it that there is
decay,
destruction, and death in this world?
What are the forces that give rise to
this decay?
And then she explains, okay,
whatever God creates is perfect. So,
angels are perfect, they're immortal,
they're eternal.
But, the elements that are in this
world,
they are not created by God. What is
created by God are the divine laws that
underlie the universe. God created the
atoms, God created created the laws
that allow these atoms to interact with
each other, okay?
So, the rays and motion of the holy
light draw forth the soul of every
animal and plant from matter able to
take form. So, it's these divine laws
that create the animals
and the plants.
But, these divine laws also necessitate
that they die in order for new forms to
come into being, okay? So, this is the
idea of evolution.
Um
we humans are special, why? Because
we are both
divinely created and created by the laws
of the universe. We have a dual nature.
And the main advantage of this dual
nature is it gives us a capacity to
imagine.
Remember the issue with God is that God
is perfect. If you're perfect, if you're
eternal, if you're immutable, you lack
imagination, because there are no
boundaries to you.
But, if you're human, you're forced to
have an imagination,
because you'll make mistakes. You will
fail. There are things that you do not
know. And the imagination gives you the
capacity to
know this world and to perfect this
world, okay?
So, that's what it means to be
fundamentally human. Okay. So, let's
recap, okay? These are the three main
messages that Dante is relaying to us
through his poetry. First of all, God is
within us. How do we know? Because we
are capable of loving others.
God is the light of love within us. The
more we love someone, the more this
light grows in us, okay? So, we must
focus on loving someone who is dear to
us. Second idea is we have the
imagination and thus responsibility to
discover the universal laws underlying
reality. God created the laws of the
universe, God created us in order to
know these laws, okay? That's very
fundamental to the idea of science. The
last idea is we can master these laws to
better our reality, okay? So, this these
are the three hidden messages of the
Divine Comedy that will influence
development of science in the Western
world. Okay.
So, I want to talk briefly about science
that it has been traditionally been
practiced in ancient societies, okay?
So, in ancient societies, the the major
ancient civilizations are China, Egypt,
and India. And you will see a lot of
similarities
among these three civilizations
civilizations on how they practice the
idea of science, okay? It's very
intuitive, it's very imaginative. Um it
will it will make sense to you, okay?
So, the first science that they focus a
lot on is the idea of sacred geometry.
I'm not I'm not sure if you've heard of
this, okay? But, the idea of sacred
geometry is that the underlying
fundamental structure
of the universe, of reality, are
geometric shapes,
okay? And from these geometric shapes,
you can give rise to every possible
reality. All right. So,
um
um this is called the egg of life, and
from the egg of life, you just keep on
expanding it, you will get
all of reality, okay?
These are actually 3D, 4D shapes. I
can't illustrate them, but if you're but
if you're curious, go online, these are
beautiful
um um ideas.
Okay?
Um so, there are two possible ways to
understand sacred geometry. The first
possible way is to understand understand
as solids, okay? So, the Egyptians
understood them as solids,
and Plato understood them as solids.
Remember Plato,
a lot of his philosophy is derived from
the Egyptians.
And the idea of sacred geometry, it's
very apparent in Plato's writings, and
he got this from the Egyptians. So,
basically the idea is that if you train
yourself on how to understand sacred
geometry and how to manipulate sacred
geometry in your head, you can access
God, okay? So, the first idea is to
understand it as solids. But, there's
another way you can understand sacred
geometry, and it's as vibrations, as
energy, as a force, okay? And this is
the way that the Chinese understand
sacred geometry, right? As chi, as life
force, also as well as the Hindus. And
so,
imagine a monk who's breathing, okay?
Who's meditating. What are you doing
What is he doing? He's breathing, and
he's meditating, and he's focusing his
energies in order to achieve the sacred
geometry within him. The the monk will
often say things like om
om
om, okay? He's causing vibrations that
try to mimic the sacred geometry.
W- Why is he doing this? Because the
belief at this time is that
if there is a God, okay? If there are a
cre- if there's a created God, the
question is, how does
it think?
Right? It's It's not going to think with
words the way we do, it's going to think
using mathematics with sacred geometry.
And by thinking,
he is going to create the underlying
universe.
And how does he do that? He does it by
breathing, breathing in, emitting sacred
geometry, and then breathing out,
breathing back in, okay? Inhaling,
exhaling. And this will give rise to the
universe. So, if you're a monk or a
priest, you practice meditation in order
to try to mimic
the act of creation. And if you are able
to succeed, then what will happen is you
harmonize yourself
with the vibrations of the universe, and
therefore you're able to access divine
energy, okay? So, that's the idea of
sacred geometry. And again, it's a very
complicated
idea, but but that's the general gist.
Um any questions?
Okay? And again, this is this make
intuitive sense, okay? This should make
intuitive sense to you. All right. The
second big field that the Egyptians, the
Chinese, and the Indians were
really compa- really passionate about is
astronomy and astrology, okay? So, the
Egyptians basically created astrology.
And the idea is that you're trying to
link the movement of the stars, the
cosmos, with events in the world, okay?
So, by understanding the movement of the
stars, you're able to divine or predict
the future of humanity, okay? Every
major
king had an astrologist in order to
divine the future through the practice
of astronomy and astrology. All right.
And the last thing is alchemy.
What is alchemy? Alchemy is basically
chemistry and sorcery combined together.
Um this is a polytheistic world, and the
idea is that because it's a polytheistic
world, it's a chaotic chaotic world, and
somehow, if you're clever enough, you're
able to hack this world, okay? Think
think of it as hockey. That there are
secrets to this world, and you are able
to take elements in this world, combine
together, and create something called
the philosopher's stone.
The philosopher's stone is the power of
God in order to give you the elixir of
immortality in order to live forever, as
well as to manipulate the environment.
So, basically to turn lead into gold.
And again, this was an extremely popular
practice um in ancient societies.
Okay? So, these are three major sciences
in
uh the primitive societies.
China, Egypt, and India. And they
um
pro- they promulgated outwards and
influenced other societies. We still
have them today, okay? There are still
people who practice alchemy,
um sacred geometry, and um astrology
today.
Okay? Um any questions about this before
I move on?
Okay, so this is primitive primitive
science. So, the question then is
what's the difference? Okay, so let's
focus on the three major differences
between
um
pre-modern science and modern science,
okay? The first major difference is it
focuses focuses focuses on the spiritual
world, on the outer worldly. All right?
And the point of science was to create
harmony between our world and the
spiritual world. Okay? Because if you
harmonize these two worlds, you can have
a more prosperous, more peaceful future.
Um today we are only focused on the
material world, the world that we can
see and know in order to create
progress. Okay? We have abandoned the
spiritual world, and we focus on
this material world in order to
manipulate it in order to promote
technological progress. And quite
honestly, we have been extremely
successful at that. In fact, I will
argue we've been too successful at that,
okay? So, that's the first major
difference between pre-modern and modern
science. Second major difference is that
pre-modern science relies entirely on
intuition and imagination, okay? You
don't do experiments. You don't um have
conferences, you don't debate. You just
meditate, you just dream.
Okay? And you often fall into trances in
order to communicate with the spiritual
world. Um in this world, they use a lot
of hello and um um
hello su- sugenics, okay? They um
a lot of psychedelics, okay? Including
uh magic mushrooms, uh a drink called
soma, which is very um important in the
Hindu religion. Um as as as as well as
the Zoroastrian religion. It's basically
a psychedelic, okay?
Um
Today, we don't rely on intuition and
imagination. We think this is um
superstitious. We rely mainly on
something called the scientific method,
okay? And in the in in um
Later on, I will discuss the scientific
method more in detail. All right?
The last thing is
in pre-modern science
people are relying on divine inspiration
in order to discover the truth. The big
question is what is truth?
Today, we care about the question how do
we know truth?
Okay, it's really the idea of in- in-
the institutionalization of doubt. Our
main Our main priority is to question
and doubt the truth.
And what And what And what will happen
is because of this
emphasis change, we've changed from what
is truth to how do we know truth, it
will launch a revolution in
techno- technological progress. All
right?
All right. So, underlying the scientific
revolution are three major theological
assumptions. Without these theological
assumptions, the scientific revolution
would not be possible, okay? So, the
first and most important idea is the
idea of monotheism. There is one God.
Okay?
And again,
um
the very idea of monotheism is also
revolutionary in human thought.
Second idea is that
God designed and willed the universe
into being. So, there is an intelligent
design to the universe.
And it's up to us to discover this
design.
God endowed us with the capacity to
discover his design and will. Okay? So,
these are the three major theological
assumptions underlying the scientific
revolution. That is why these
That is why the scientific scientific
revolution happened in Western Europe
and not, say, in China or the Islamic
world or India, okay? Because you need
these three theological assumptions.
Okay. So, what do these assumptions
bring us? Okay, so let's look at poly-
polytheism again. Throughout most of
human history um most societies have
been thought polytheistic. What is the
difference between a polytheistic
worldview of science and a monotheistic
worldview of science, okay? So, I I I I
need you to memorize this chart, okay?
The first major difference is the poly-
polytheistic system, there's there's
really no design. There's really no
progress. It's just chaos and struggle.
But in the monotheistic worldview, there
is an underlying truth to the universe.
Okay? That's the first difference.
Second major difference is
the idea of randomness. Things happen
for no particular reason. If you
um
win the lottery, that's great, okay?
But if you lose all your wealth
that's just random, okay? There's It's
just fate. It's just destiny. There's no
purpose or no design to your fate. But
in a monotheistic world, there's the
idea of good and evil.
Things happen to you that benefit you if
you're doing good.
But if you're doing evil, then bad
things will happen to you, okay? So,
there's a very um
There's a deep sense that God is in our
lives
orchestrating events. The last major
difference is that between fate and
progress, okay? If there's truth in this
world, if there's goodness in this
world, then we have a responsibility
to progress by doing good and by
discovering this truth.
Okay?
That's why I keep on emphasizing this,
but mon- monotheism is really an
intellectual revolution first and
foremost.
Okay. So, um
the scientific revolution happens, and
what drives it, okay? There are three
major forces that drive the scientific
revolution. The first is the idea
of the Protestant Reformation and the
Counter-Reformation. So, the Protestants
have come and they're challenging the
authority of the church, and the church
responds by
um what's something called the
Counter-Reformation. There is this
belief or this is prejudice
um that the church is anti-science. The
church The Catholic church is not
anti-science. In fact, the both the
Protestants and the Catholic church are
trying to use science in order to
promote their legitimacy and authority,
okay? So, the Protestants are heavily uh
devoted to science because because they
want to understand the will and mind of
God. The Catholics themselves are also
promoting science. Um the Catholics will
create a new society called the Jesuits
who are renowned for um for for being
great scientists. In fact, a lot of
universities in this world were founded
by Jesuits.
Um a lot of Jesuits came to China, and
they promoted knowledge and science in
China. And this has been true for many
centuries, okay? So, both the Catholic
church and the Protestant movement,
they're all in a struggle to use science
in order to promote their own authority
and legitimacy, okay? So, that's the
first major force driving the scientific
revolution.
Second is war. During this time, Europe
is in constant state of war. It's
fighting amongst themselves
um between the Catholics and the
Protestants.
Um
it's also fighting with the Muslims,
okay? The Ottoman Empire, which is at
this point um the strongest empire in um
in the world. All right? And the last
idea that's driving science is the age
of exploration and conquest. As Europe
is trying to expand outwards, if they're
going to North America, they're going to
South America, they need better
navigation tools. They need compasses.
They need um
um astrolabes, okay? They They
So, science solves all three problems,
okay?
Okay. So,
again
the scientific revolution, the best way
to remember the scientific revolution is
it's a fundamental change from asking
what is truth to how do we know truth?
Okay? How can we know truth?
And
believe it or not, but no one really
bothered to ask this question before.
How can we know truth? Okay? Um And
because science is asking this question,
how do we know truth, what it's really
doing is it's separating itself from
religion.
And putting itself above religion, okay?
Because religion purports to be the
truth, right? And what science is saying
is like, how do you know if you if
you're right?
Well, we know if you're right because we
have methods to test you, okay? So,
science is putting itself above
religion. And as you can imagine, this
will create conflicts
within the Catholic Church very, very
soon.
Mainly in the trial of Galileo.
Okay.
So,
because science asks this question, how
do we know truth? What it does is it
creates the scientific method. Okay?
And the scientific method is composed of
three main
elements. The first is
you ask questions and you propose
hypothesis.
So, there are no questions now that are
out of bounds.
And you have to think of solutions and
ideas to solve these questions. Okay, so
that's the first step. Second step is
there are these processes and protocols
for testing hypothesis. Experimentation
basically. All right, so
only if you can experiment,
only if you can only if your hypothesis
matches experimental results can it be
true.
Now, last
thing is it creates a system of doubt
and criticism in order to test all
experimental results. And today we call
them academic societies and peer review
journals. Okay, so if you're a scientist
working today at a university,
whatever results you have you have you
must first publish and then you have to
present your journal results
to a conference of peers who will
criticize you and they will look for
flaws in your argument. And this is an
extremely effective system on how to
know what is true. And again, because of
the system, it's allowed for a
remarkable explosion of wealth
and technology and progress in the world
today.
And this is the chart that shows us,
okay? So,
for most of human history, progress,
meaning productivity, has been flat.
And then starting around the year 1700,
it starts to exponentially rise.
Okay?
And this has meant that we are now able
to feed more and more people. So,
before 1700, you really couldn't get
above a few hundred million people. And
now we are at nine we are projected to
reach nine billion people. And you can
ask, is this a good thing? And I will
argue it's not a good thing, but it
shows us the remarkable power of
science. Okay?
All right.
So, now the question then is
what caused the scientific method to
arise?
And it really has to do with a major
debate among scientists.
It was it was the geocentric versus the
heliocentric debate.
Okay?
Now,
what's interesting is that
if you look at the Egyptians, they knew
that
the sun was the center of the universe.
That's why their god was the sun god,
Ra. Okay?
But
by the time you had to you hit the
Greeks,
there was now all this divergence
between those who believed that the
universe revolved around the sun and
those who believed it revolved around
the Earth.
In about 150, a Greek scientist named
Ptolemy working in Egypt, he developed
the first comprehensive
cosmological system. And this cosmo
cosmological system which he wrote in a
book called the Almagest,
he made certain
arguments. Okay, the first argument is
that
the Earth stands still.
Okay? The Earth
does not move. It doesn't revolve. Okay?
Second is that all other celestial
bodies, including the moon, including
the stars, the planets, revolve around
the Earth in a circular motion.
Okay? Why? Because in the heavens it is
assumed that
everything is perfect.
Okay? So, for example,
on planet Earth we breathe something
called air.
Right? We we air oxygen is what gives us
life. But up there in space,
air becomes ether.
Ether is the air that the gods breathe.
Ether is what allows the world the
heavens to be perfect.
Okay?
And so
and this is the Arabic edition of the
Almagest. And as as you can see, there
you can't read this, but there's a lot
of mathematical detail
in
the book. And because Ptolemy's
perspective aligned with theology, the
Bible,
it was accepted
it was accepted truth for
over a thousand years. Okay?
The Islamic golden age relied heavily on
Ptolemy's understanding of the cosmos.
But the first person to suggest that
this model is wrong is
Copernicus. Okay, who is a Polish
polymath. He did many things. He did
astrology. He also did astronomy. Okay,
and when he died in 1543,
he proposed the heliocentric model. Now,
what's really important for us to
remember is that Copernicus was a devout
Catholic. And many of his friends were
major figures within the Catholic
Church. And guess what? They were
extremely supportive
of his
theory. In fact, they want they wanted
him to publish his theory.
Okay? Why? Because at this point,
there is no conflict between science and
religion.
So, the saying back then is
it is the job of the church, the
Catholic Church, to tell you how to go
to heaven,
not how the heavens go.
Okay? So, the Catholic Church didn't
really care
one way. Didn't care about the
geocentric model or the heliocentric
model. Didn't care at all.
So,
Copernicus was heavily supported. The
problem with Copernicus is that the
mathematics didn't really make sense.
Okay? So, if I put two books in front of
you,
Copernicus' book called On the
Revolutions of the Celestial Spheres, or
Ptolemy's book, well, most scientists
would tell you that Ptolemy's book is
better, okay? There's more math. It's
it's more well argued. And the reason
why is
Copernicus, his idea is new and so there
was not that much time he didn't have
that much time to refine it. People
didn't really have time to work on it.
Whereas Ptolemy, people
thousand people have been working at
over the centuries, okay?
So, the geocentric model, it is much
more refined, much more accepted at this
point than the heliocentric model.
We there this this man, his name is
Tycho Brahe and he is
a Danish polymath as well.
He comes from a very noble family and he
spent a lot of his time
doing observations.
Okay? He
collected a lot of data. He observed how
the planets revolve. And his conclusion
is
that
the geocentric and the heliocentric
model are both correct. And this and
this and his proposal was that
Earth was the center of the world, but
the planets revolve around the sun.
Okay? So, the sun revolved around the
Earth and every other system revolved
around the sun.
Okay? So, that's what he
that's what he derived from his
data.
Now, he he had a protege named Johannes
Kepler.
He's a German and he looked at the data
and he
and he discovered that the data actually
makes the heliocentric model
actually supports the heliocentric model
more than the geocentric model.
And but because he is not a member of
the Catholic Church, he's a Lutheran,
okay?
The Catholic Church couldn't really do
any do anything about him.
All right? And what's remarkable about
Kepler is that just from this data, he
was able to make certain predictions
about the stars that we've confirmed
over time. The first is that the sun
so every revolves revolves around the
sun. His problem though is that he
didn't put the sun at the center of the
universe. He put something else at the
center of the universe. The sun revolved
around that and the Earth revolved
around the sun.
Second major law of
motion is that the orbit is actually not
circular. It's elliptical. Okay? That's
what the data was telling him.
All right? And this goes against
theology because remember in theology,
the heavens are perfect. Right? That
means that's where God lives. But
um
Kepler is saying, nope, the universe
sorry, the orbit is elliptical.
And then what he what else he did that
was revolutionary is that he he
developed he discovered that there was a
correlation
between this orbit
and the mass of the planet, okay? And
this will give rise to Newton. But
Kepler
made all these revolutionary
discoveries.
Now comes Galileo.
And Galileo
he lives in Florence at this time.
And so he's under the purview of the
Catholic Church.
So, he comes from a pretty normal
background. When he grew up, he wanted
to be a monk,
but his dad
wanted him wanted him to become a doctor
instead.
And then he they made a compromise and
he said, I'll go study mathematics. But
his dad was insistent that he go study
medicine. Eventually,
Galileo managed to
go to do what he wanted and just do
science, okay?
Um
at this point, they invented a
telescope. And this was not a great
telescope. So, the telescope could give
you three times the magnification of the
human eye, okay? But it's not that
great. But with this telescope this new
invention, Galileo did amazing things.
First thing he did was he discovered
that the Jupiter had moons.
And this was revolutionary because it
was assumed that everything revolved
around the planet um Earth.
But now he showed that moons revolved
around Jupiter.
He also recognized that um
from the Earth, you're able to see
um Venus spin around us.
And that also was revolutionary because
it was assumed that
um
Earth stood still and all the planets
stood still.
Okay?
So, he wrote this book and it was a
sensation. He became like the court
scientist to the Medici family and the
Catholic Church thought this book was
great, okay? But the thing about
Galileo, which is very important, is
that he was a very arrogant man.
And because he was promoting the
heliocentric model, he was coming into
conflict with a lot of academics that
were extremely well established
who made their living off the geocentric
model, okay? So, they're having these
arguments and Galileo's
um arguments were very limited.
Remember, this is a new idea. It's not
really supported by mathematics. It's
not really supported by a lot of data,
okay?
So, Galileo's entire logic was
I speak to God. I know the truth and
you're all idiots, okay? That was
basically how he spoke to his enemies.
And as you can imagine, he had more and
more enemies. And as you can also
imagine, his enemies were devising ways
to get at Galileo.
One thing that Galileo was saying
privately that he was should not have
been saying is that
people were saying to him, "Listen, um
this heliocentric model, it's fine, but
it goes against scripture, okay? Let's
look at scripture. Scripture says that
um the Earth, it's firm and immovable,
okay? That's what the Bible says. Also,
if you look if you look at Genesis, it's
clear that God created the Earth first
and then he created the heavens, the sun
and the moon and the stars. So,
logically,
everything should revolve around Earth.
So, Galileo, how do you explain this
conflict between your theory of
uh the heliocentric model and
scripture?"
And Galileo's response was
"It's my job to interpret scripture."
And this, as you remember from last
week, it's heresy.
Okay? If you disagree with the church,
that's not heresy.
That could just be ignorance, okay? But
if you believe that you are above the
church, if you refuse to accept the
authority of the church, if you believe
that I interpret the the Bible better
than the church, that is heresy.
Okay? So, Galileo was called before the
Inquisition.
He was explained asked to explain
himself. And Galileo was pretty
confident, you know, he had the support
of the Medicis. He was he was a very
famous author. He was extremely
intelligent. He thought that God loved
him, okay?
So, as you can imagine, it was a
complete disaster.
Uh it was a disastrous meeting. The
Inquisition told him to shut up, okay?
You you can write anything you want
privately, but do not promote your views
anymore.
And because if if you were guilty of
heresy, you could be burned at the
stake, Galileo had no choice
but to follow this order, okay? That is
until
um
1632. What happened in 1632? Well, the
old Pope died and a new Pope, Urban the
VIII, came into power.
Who is Urban the VIII? Well, he was a
very good friend of Galileo's. And Urban
the VIII was a huge admirer of of
Galileo's, okay? So, Galileo felt he now
had permission
to get back at at his enemies. So, he
wrote a book called Dialogue Concerning
the Two Chief World Systems. And it was
it was basically like almost like a
Platonic dialogue, okay?
Where he presented his argument again
for the heliocentric model.
Not not only that, but he made fun of
his enemies. So, it's a dialogue
and the chief enemy of Galileo, his name
was Simplicitus, okay? Simplicitus,
Not only that, but he put into the mouth
of Simplicitus a lot of the arguments
from Pope Urban the VIII, okay? So, he
was making fun of the Pope even though
they were very good friends. So, you can
as you can imagine,
the Pope was really pissed. At first, he
banned this book. And what happens when
you ban a book? You make it into a
national bestseller, okay? So, everyone
was reading this book. So, now Urban the
VIII was really angry and so he called
for the Inquisition, okay? So, Galileo
was hauled before the Inquisition and
Galileo now had to explain himself. And
Galileo was coming up with a lot of like
really silly excuses. So, so he said is,
"Listen,
this book, it's it's a satire.
It's a thought experiment.
I know that the heliocentric model is
wrong.
And so, I wrote this book to um
as an intellectual exercise to see how
wrong it could be and to see if it could
be right, okay? So, so so so he's saying
things same things like this."
Didn't work. And they uh basically put
him
um under arrest, okay? At this point,
um Galileo's friends pleaded with the
Pope and the Pope said, "Fine, I'm a
generous person. I will commute his
sentence to house arrest for the rest of
his life, okay?" So, that is the story
of Galileo.
All right? So, you can make the argument
that
it was Galileo's personality
that was just responsible for the trial
for his trial and downfall. Cuz it was
his hubris. It's a very classic classic
uh Greek tragedy. But
um historically,
that's not what how we remember this the
story. The reason why is again,
remember, there's a major conflict
between the Protestants and the
Catholics. So, the Protestants will use
this trial as propaganda against the
church.
And the Protestants will say, "You see
how anti-science
the uh church is?" And Galileo will be
will be remembered now as the father of
modern science because he put science
above religion.
And even though Galileo
um
was disgraced during his time,
eventually what will happen is the
Florentines, the people of Florence,
they will dig up his grave and put uh
his body beside Michelangelo and Dante.
All right? That's how that's that's how
they much they revered uh the
contribution of Galileo.
Okay.
All right. So, um
again, even though the theory of
heliocentrism, it is correct, the
mathematics didn't make any sense. At
this time in history, if you had a team
of scientists go and look at the
geocentric argument versus a
heliocentric argument, they would say
the geocentric argument makes more
scientific sense, okay?
It was not until Newton when the
mathematics came into being that allowed
for the heliocentric model to be widely
accepted. Newton, as you know, he's the
person who created calculus. The
calculus you're learning in school,
guess what? He was responsible for the
creation of calculus.
Now, what's really interesting for us to
know about Newton is Newton didn't
really see himself as a mathematician
mathematician or scientist. These were
side hobbies.
What he really was was a theolo-
theologian, okay? So, he spent most of
his time actually reading the Bible
because he was convinced that within the
Bible were the secrets of the universe.
Specifically, he wanted to know
when the world would end, okay? And he
and he spent his most of his life doing
these calculations and he told us that
the world will probably end, I don't
know, 2060, okay? 2050, 2060, around
there.
So, he spent most of his time doing
theology. This is important for us
because
even at this time, even as the
scientific revolution is gaining steam,
there's no separation between religion
and science.
People understood faith as a very
important cornerstone of science.
Without faith, how could you have the
energy and the inspiration to understand
the mind of God? Okay?
Um Newton is also famous for being an
alchemist. So, he spent most of his time
also doing these science experiments
where he trying to combine different
elements.
Unfortunately, chemistry at this point,
it's very primitive. So, he's taking
mercury, okay? He was convinced that
mercury will lead to the philosopher's
stone and he was eating it. He was
tasting it. And as a result, he had a
lot of mercury poisoning problems. He
couldn't sleep. He had delusions. His
hair was falling out.
Um he had mercury poisoning, okay?
But
at the same time, he had the inspiration
to come up with the mathematics to prove
the heliocentric model is correct, okay?
Um the prin- the book he wrote is called
the Principia.
Um at this time, Latin is the
um universal language of of scientists,
right?
And also by the time also, guys, um
at this time, they're not called
scientists, they're called natural
philosophers.
All right? Science is considered part of
philosophy.
All right, so in 1687,
they this debate ended with the
publication of this book.
Newton used mathematics
to prove once and for all um, this the
the the heliocentric model. Uh, this is
one page from
the Principia. As you can see, there are
a lot of mathematics, there are a lot of
diagrams, okay?
Um, in this book you also find his laws
of motions. So, Newton's great insight
was that the probably the laws of
attraction, gravity, that govern this
world probably govern
the heavens as well, okay? So, before it
was assumed that the heavens and the
earth were separate. And now he's saying
that, "No, these are combined together."
And he created
um, laws of planetary motion, okay? If
he he figured out the mathematics that
um,
that
told us relationship between the the
size of the planets, the mass, and how
they orbited, okay?
Now, the problem though, he had a huge
problem. The problem is he had a
correlation, he had the mathematical
correlation, but he didn't know why the
correlation existed. He didn't have the
he couldn't solve the causation problem,
okay? There's just no way that God would
spend all his time moving the planets
around. He was much too busy. So, there
had to be there had to be an underlying
cause. He didn't know what it was
though, okay? And and who figured it
out? Well,
Einstein figured it out, right?
So, we So, at this point
in 1905, we knew that
there was a correlation between the size
of the planet and how it moved, okay?
And gravity.
But we didn't know why. And it was the
genius of Einstein to figure it out.
Now, you you remember Einstein because
of his famous equation E equals MC
squared, okay? What is What is this What
does E equals MC squared mean? It means
that
mass and energy are correlated. And this
is a revolution. We we didn't we didn't
understand this before, right? We just
We just assumed that solids and
vibrations are different. And what
Einstein is saying is that in order for
a solid to exist, there had to be
vibrations in the first place.
And this this formula tells us that
within all objects, there is almost an
infinite amount of energy, okay? Because
C is the speed of light.
And why is this important? Because this
formula will allow us to develop the
nuclear bomb,
right? By splitting the atom, you can
create almost an infinite amount of
energy in this world.
Okay, so that's a major contribution
of Einstein. But at his at at his time,
he was mainly known for figuring out the
causation problem in space, okay? And
what um, and how Einstein figured out is
by developing a new idea called
space-time.
He believed that in the heavens, space
there was a space-time curvature. And
so, what was happening was this, a mass,
a huge object, it would go into the
space-time curvature and warp it. And
because it warped it, it drew things
into its orbit.
And the and then these things would have
to move around
this solid, okay?
So, space-time curvature now helps us
understand uh, the laws of planetary
motion, first developed by Kepler and
then by and then refined by Newton,
okay? And what's amazing about about
Einstein is
and and this is like
this will blow your mind, okay? But he
did all this while sitting at a desk at
a patent office in Switzerland. He was
not allowed to court. He was not at a
university. He was just thinking by
himself. He was daydreaming, okay?
So, um, this was just an incredible
achievement.
Okay.
And so, um, the mathematics is very
complicated, okay? But all you need you
need to understand is that he figured
out that there's a mathematical
relationship between the mass of the
object and the space-time curvature,
okay? And this formula
um, tells us what the relationship is.
And the And why mathematics is important
is it allows us to make predictions. And
these predictions will tell us if the
if the science actually works or not,
okay? If the model, the theory makes
sense or not. And so, Einstein's theory
of relativity, space-time curvature, it
is one of the most successful models in
history because it predicts the black
hole, okay? The black hole is almost um,
solid that is infinitely
um, massive and therefore it attracts
everything into it and sucks everything
into it, including light. Okay, so it
predicts the idea of the
uh, black hole. And we discovered the
black hole, all right? So, this um,
confirms the theory of of relativity.
The um, the
theory of relativity also predicts the
Big Bang because
um,
space-time The idea of space-time is
that space is in motion, right? That's
why you have time because it's in
motion. Well, if it's in motion, then
where did it start? It had It had to be
like a starting point. And that's why
scientists, not Einstein, Einstein was
actually against the idea of the Big
Bang, but lots of scientists believe
that you need a Big Bang, okay? And and
so, we have a working model of the Big
Bang. The problem with this model is
that there's actually a lot of evidence
against this,
okay? So, so there are two examples. The
first example is using the Hubble
telescope, the most advanced telescope
in the world, which which is now in
outer space, we've discovered that there
are actually galaxies
that came before they were due, okay?
So, the idea of Big Bang is that it is
massive energy explosion and so, the
galaxies will develop later.
But our data tells us the galaxies came
before, much much earlier than we
expected, okay? That's that's the first
thing. Second problem that we have with
the Big Bang model is that
this universal expansion, it is not
constant. There are times when it
actually speeds up, which makes no
sense. Why would it speed up, okay? So,
um, this Big Bang model, a lot of
scientists are now trying to re-examine
it.
Okay, the problem is, and this is a huge
problem, is we have we don't have a
better theory.
And so, to get around the problem of
these sis sis mathematical
inconsistencies in the model, scientists
created a new concept called
uh, dark energy.
Dark energy. Now, you think to yourself,
dark energy means we can't see it.
No, that's not what it means, okay?
And you're like, "Well, dark energy
means we can't measure it." No, that's
not what it means. Dark energy means we
don't know what it is, okay? Doesn't
mean it exists and we can't see it. It
just means we have no idea what it is.
We can't explain why the Big Bang is
expanding really fast at certain points
and really slow at other points. And so,
we just say it must be dark energy,
okay?
Does that make sense, guys? So, dark
energy dark energy is not something that
you can't see. It's just something we
don't have no idea what it is,
okay?
All right. So,
these are the theories, okay? But the
person who was most responsible for the
creation of the scientific method, his
name is actually Francis Bacon.
And he spent his entire life promoting
the idea of scientific processes and
methods.
Um, he's most most well known for his
book The New Atlantis. So,
uh, in the new new Atlantis, which is
like a novel, the protagonist, he ends
up in the on an island where they have
the most advanced science in the world.
And and what and the reason why they
have the most advanced science in the
world is because they turned science
into a bureaucracy, a very specialized
bureaucracy, okay? So, I'm not going to
read all of it, all right? But there are
different uh, offices, different
bureaucracies for different functions.
So, for example, we have three that try
new experiments such as themselves think
good. These we call pioneers or miners,
okay? So, you you have an office, a
bureaucracy specifically to do
experiments, which means that you have
an office, a bureaucracy specifically
come up with hypotheses to ask
questions, okay?
Also,
um, we have three that take care out of
them to direct new experiments of a
higher light more penetrating into
nature than the former. These we call
lamps. So, you have a team to actually
audit
these experiments and figure out how to
improve them, okay? And the and then um,
lastly, we have three that raise the
former discoveries by experiments into
great observations, axioms, and
aphorisms. These we call interpreters of
nature. So, these are theoreticians.
They're the ones who take these this
this experimental data and combine it
into a theory.
And so,
Bacon is proposing a scientific
bureaucracy. And guess what, guys?
We have basically achieved his vision
today. If you look at science today,
it's essentially a bureaucracy,
all right?
Now, one of the foundations of this
bureaucracy was the founding of the
Royal Society of London in 1660s in
1660, okay? Why is this important?
Because for the first time, scientists
are allowed to present their findings
before a group of peers who will
question and doubt them. And this will
enhance their research process, okay?
So, the founding of the Royal Society
was fun funda fundamental. As you can
imagine what will come next is
publications, magazines that
will showcase
a lot of
these new new discoveries.
Um the founding members of the Royal
Society include Christopher Wren, who is
a very famous architect,
as well as Robert Hooke, who is a very
famous um
chemist.
Okay.
So, that's a basic background in into
the history of the scientific
revolution. Um
today we are asking ourselves a very
deep question.
So, the scientific revolution separated
science from religion.
And there's a lot of concern that this
is is this has created a lot of ethical
issues within science, okay? So, let's
look at three major issues. The first
major issue is the idea of artificial
intelligence. Basically, we're trying to
create God.
And that's a huge concern. What happens
when the computers are much smarter than
humans, okay? Second is the idea of
nanotechnology, where we're trying to go
into the atomic level and change the
laws of nature, okay? We're trying to
defy God. The third is the idea of
genetics, where we are trying to change
people's genetic
blueprint so that we can have designer
babies, so that
babies will not will be free from
cancer. Also, we're trying to develop
immortality, okay? We're looking for the
exact the elixir
immortality. Okay, so these are three
massive ethical debates
within science.
And my argument to you today is that
this is the wrong question to ask.
Okay? This is the wrong question to ask.
These are not possible within the
current scientific framework that we
have today.
In fact, I would make the argument that
these three are essentially illusions.
Hocus pocus, magic. Or you you you you
can even go as far as to say they are
deliberate scams.
So, artificial intelligence is the
example that we are most calm with that
that we're most fam- familiar with,
okay?
So, I'm sure you've all used ChatGPT.
Is it any good? No, it's not.
Will it get any better? No, it won't,
okay? So, but there's so much hype
around it.
Okay? Um I I I I I don't have time to go
into artificial intelligence, but if you
want to
know more about artificial intelligence
and why it's a scam, I can do so later
on, okay? Just just ask me. All right.
So, the real problem is this.
Okay, the real problem is this. Science
has become an imperial bureaucracy.
That's the real issue.
All right?
If you think about the world we live in
today,
the field that is most like the imperial
bureaucracy of China
um is science today.
Science is above nation, it is above
government, it does it does things by
itself, okay? And what's science doing?
Science is promoting
um its its own bureaucracy.
There's if there's no accountability,
if there's no responsibility, if
scientists actually have to tell us what
they're doing,
then it's not that they will become God,
it's more like they'll become corrupt
bureaucrats. Does that make sense?
It's more likely that they will take all
these billions of dollars the government
throw at them and they'll just waste it
all.
Okay? Why? Because
they can.
It's much easier for people to be lazy,
greedy, and corrupt than it is for them
to become God, okay?
All right. So, let me let me let me
explain.
Okay. So,
I I know this is a hard idea,
but genius does not come from hard work.
It does not come from scientific process
or scientific method. It comes from
intuition, imagination, and inspiration,
okay? So, remember when Einstein, he was
just daydreaming his theories.
Okay? Remember when
Newton, he was working on theology, he
was working on alchemy, and he and then
he developed the ideas of calculus,
okay? This is this is true consistently
throughout history. This is a passage
from the book The Cosmic Serpent by
Jeremy Narby, okay? I'll just read it to
you.
Many of science's central ideas seem to
come from beyond the limits of
rationalism. People do not
logically deduce these ideas.
Rene Descartes dreams of an angel who
explains the basic principles of
materialist rationalism to him. And this
is no different from Muhammad, who was
meditating in a cave and the angel
Gabriel appeared before him. It's
religious.
Albert Einstein daydreams in a tram
approaching another and conceives the
theory of relativity.
Right?
James Watson scribbles on a newspaper in
a train, then rides his bicycle to reach
the conviction that DNA has the form of
a double helix.
So, what gives rise to great science, to
great ideas?
It Well, imagination,
intuition, and also faith that you are
correct. Right? That's Galileo. Galileo
was actually convinced that he was right
even though the science
was very sloppy, okay? In fact, there's
this very famous story where
Einstein in the 1930s and '40s, he was
having a huge argument with scientists
who were arguing for quantum mechanics,
specifically Niels Bohr.
Okay? So,
um if you look go go and look back in
1930s and '40s and you look at their
arguments, what you will find is that
Einstein was very clear, was very
logical, and was very
um
scientific style,
okay? And you will find that Niels Bohr
was unclear, illogical, and very sloppy
with science. But
Einstein was wrong, Niels Bohr was
right. Today quantum mechanics is a
science that underlies all the
technology that we have today, including
the computer, okay? The semiconductor,
the transistor computer.
All right? So, so that's a really
important thing that we have to remember
about science. At first, it seems wrong,
but because of the people who believe in
it have so much conviction faith, they
eventually triumph, okay?
All right? So, that's how science
develops. And this this is the argument
of
um Thomas Kuhn in his book The Structure
of Scientific Revolutions, okay? This is
a book that I highly recommend.
Um if you ever study the history of
science, this is a book the first book
that you will read. Because he goes into
how science develops over the centuries.
The central argument is that science
does not develop
like piecemeal and slowly and
methodically, okay? It goes through
revolutions and paradigm shifts.
All right.
Okay, so um
so I
I know this is going to be a bit long,
but it's really important that we read
him, okay?
Paradigms gain their status because they
are more successful than their counter
competitors in solving a few problems
that the group of practitioners has come
to recognize as acute. All right? So,
Ptolemy first time was considered
revolutionary because he solved the
problem of why why is it the moon
revolves around the Earth, okay? He he
provided a cosmology that was simple and
which fit into theology.
To be more successful is not, however,
to be either completely successful with
a single problem or not successful with
any large number, okay? So, Ptolemy's
solution only solved a few problems. It
was not the complete solution.
The success of a paradigm is at the
start largely a promise of success
discoverable in selected and
still incomplete examples.
Okay? So, a the paradigm at first, it's
actually promising, but it's not at all
convincing.
Normal science, okay? The science that
we practice today
consists in the actualization of that
promise, an actualization achieved by
extending the knowledge of those facts
that the paradigm displays as
particularly revealing, by increasing
the extent of the match between those
facts and the paradigm's predictions,
and by further articulation of the
paradigm itself. Okay, so this is really
important, guys. Science is not about
discovery, it's about refinement.
Does that make sense?
Science will not give us new ideas,
science will take existing ideas and
fine-tune them into something that we
can believe and that we can use to drive
technological innovation.
Okay?
All right, so let's look at another
passage. Turn now to another, more
difficult and more revealing aspect of
the parallelism between puzzles and the
problems of normal science. If it is to
classify as a puzzle, a problem must be
characterized by more than an assured
solution.
There must also be rules that limit both
the nature of acceptable solutions and
the steps by which they are to be
obtained. To solve a jigsaw puzzle is
not, for example, merely to make a
picture. Either child or a contemporary
artist could do that by scattering
selected
pieces as abstract shapes upon some
neutral ground. Okay, so this is really
important. What he's saying is this.
Science today solves jigsaw puzzles.
They're trying to take a larger model
and fine-tune pieces
that make the model much more elegant.
It's not trying to reimagine the model.
It's not trying to over-trim the model.
It's not trying to add new pieces to the
model. All it's doing is fine-tuning
existing pieces.
It's like you take a jigsaw puzzle and
and there's and there's one exactly one
solution to the jigsaw puzzle. If you
don't provide that solution, you're
wrong.
Okay? Does that make sense? That's what
science is.
Nevertheless, such a picture would not
be a solution, okay? So, what he's
saying is
if you come up with new picture to the
jigsaw puzzle, you might be creative,
um you might be interesting, you might
be imaginative, but you're wrong. Okay?
Scientists cannot accept your solution.
To achieve that, all the pieces must be
used, the plain sides must be turned
out, and they must be interlocked
without forcing until no holes remain,
okay? Those are among the rules that
govern jigsaw puzzle solutions.
So, if you are a scientist working
today, you're literally solving a jigsaw
puzzle. The solution Everyone knows the
solution. If you If you provide
something that goes against the accepted
solution, you'll be You will not be
accepted.
Okay?
All right.
So, he concludes, "But paradigm debates
are not really about relative
problem-solving ability, though for good
reasons they are usually couched in
those terms. Instead, the issue in which
paradigm should in the future guide
research on problems, many of which
neither competitor can yet claim to
resolve completely. A decision between
alternate ways of practicing science is
called for, and the circumstances that
this that decision must be
based less on past achievement than on
future promise. The man who embraces a
new paradigm at an early stage must
often do so in defiance of the evidence
provided by problem-solving." Okay. So,
this is hard for us to understand, but
if you are to to be a true innovator,
it's not that you come up with a new
solution
to a problem. It's that you must defy
the basic premises
of bureaucratic science.
"He must, that is, have faith that the
new paradigm will succeed with the many
large problems that confront it, knowing
only that the older paradigm has failed
with few. A decision of that kind can
only be made on faith." Okay. So, this
is why
it's almost impossible to separate
religion from science. If a new
discovery is to be made, that person
must believe that he is sent by God to
tell us the truth. Okay? That's Galileo.
Galileo, if you actually met the person,
you would think this guy's a complete
All right? He's arrogant, he's
obnoxious, all he does is make fun of
you, okay? But he's driven by a divine
mission to spread the truth.
And because he created this conflict
with the church, it became an national
um
controversy and focused attention of
scientists and and they tried to resolve
this issue.
Okay? So, science scientific innovation
genius, it's not a
tea party, all right? It's a revolution.
Okay. So, um
I'm going to summarize what we've
discussed. Okay? Because because um this
was a lot.
Okay, but but but but I want to
summarize what we did
so that you have a basic framework to
understand
um
what I'm I'm talking about because um
there'll be other classes on these
topics, all right? Um we'll we'll be
discussing quantum mechanics at a future
date.
So, I I I want to make sure that um we
understand the argument. Okay. So, our
argument is this.
For most of history, science
was part of religion.
Science was about validating this um
religion.
But this creates a problem we call
confirmation bias.
Confirmation bias.
Meaning that we will only
look at evidence that supports our
claims. And we do this every single day,
okay? We all want to be right, we all
want to feel good, we all want to be
con-
by the world around us.
Okay? So,
um there's a very famous experiment
called the Dunning-Kruger.
You've heard of this, right? Okay,
Dunning-Kruger.
The Dunning-Kruger experiment.
So, Dunning Kruger were two American
psychologists, and they were teaching um
an undergraduate class of foreign
students. And they made these students
do two things. The first thing is they
made every student take an IQ test.
Okay? The second thing is they asked
student how they think they did on that
IQ test. Were you in the top 5%? Were
you in the bottom 5%? Were you average?
Okay? And it turned out that once they
um looked at all the results, not one
student
predicted
his or her class ranking.
Those who did really well, the top 5%,
it was pretty easy for them, so they
assumed it was easy for everyone, okay?
So, they underestimated their
performance by about 10%.
Those
who did the worst
didn't really know
uh what was asked of them, okay? So,
they overestimated their performance. In
fact, those who got the most wrong were
the worst students. So, maybe they were
top They were the bottom 10%, but they
thought they were average, okay?
And what this tells us is this.
Doubt
self-doubt
it's really the mark of genius, okay? If
you're able to doubt yourself, if you're
able to question yourself, if you're if
you're able to self-reflect, that's a
sign of an excellent student, okay? In
fact, the best sign of of excellent
student.
So, the question then is,
how do you take
um
how do you bring doubt into science?
What you do is you separate science from
religion and you create a bureaucracy
around science in order to instill doubt
in the scientific process, okay?
That's the solution um proposed by
Francis Bacon. And again, it is the most
successful solution in human history,
all right? So,
um the scientific process is hypothesis,
experiment,
um data analysis,
um
Okay?
Replication.
Okay? Does that make sense? You have a
hypothesis, you you then test it out, if
it works according to data, you then
have to replicate the experiment to make
sure that you are correct. Now, the
beauty of this model is that you can
actually
um ch- you can actually make it into a
bureaucracy, right? So, each department
does its own thing.
And so, what happens is that each
department is
inspecting and auditing the work of the
previous department to make sure the
results are
accurate and correct.
Okay, does that make sense? And it turns
out if you do this way,
well, it's revolutionary. And it
explains the world that we live in
today. It explains why scientific
progress has been so fast
and uh so remarkable these past 300, 400
years, okay?
But embedded in the system
are lots and lots of other issues, okay?
Which Which um
I will discuss. The first is the idea of
political control.
It takes a lot of resources to run this
system, and as a result, you can allow
politicians to come in and interfere
with the science, okay? That's the first
problem. Second problem is that
over time, each department will
over-specialize.
Okay? You have over-specialization,
which means that these departments are
now unable to communicate with with with
each other because the underlying
assumptions um the science under of of
each of each department will be
different, okay? So, if you want
experiments, we use you usually have in-
instruments, okay? All these instruments
are so complicated
that normal scientists don't really
understand what you're doing.
Okay? So, that's the second problem,
over-specialization.
The um
um third problem
is
um the idea of accountability.
Okay?
How do you know
if each department is
doing their job or not?
Right? You you you can't because now
they're over-specialized.
The word we use is they are now
um aloof.
Okay? So, there are many problems with
this system. Another problem is
insularity.
Meaning that you have to spend like 20
years in school before you could even be
even enter the system.
Okay, in insularity creates gatekeeping,
which means that
only if you play by the rules,
only if you've vetted you enter the
system.
Okay?
And as result,
you no longer have any creativity.
So, this is the great irony
of science.
Um
science was
initiated, inspired by the genius of
Galileo, Newton, and Einstein.
But today, science has developed to a
point where it no longer welcomes
Galileo, Newton, or Einstein. Okay? Why?
Because Galileo is an He
doesn't get along with other people.
They won't let him in. Newton is crazy,
right? He's alchemist. He He believes
that the Bible will reveal the end of
the world. He's crazy. They won't let
him in. Einstein is really bad at
mathematics. He doesn't He He would fail
all these mathematics tests in order to
get into the system. He would probably
He probably would not get into graduate
school today.
Right? So, this is the world we live in.
So, don't worry about
artificial intelligence. Don't worry
about uh billionaires living forever.
Don't worry about nanotechnology, okay?
Worry about the fact that we've come to
a point in our in our civilization where
we are now incapable
of
innovation.
Okay?
All right.
So, that's it.
Any questions?
Okay. Just to make just a small
observation, sir.
Okay. When you
When you set up this lecture, you talked
about pre-modern science and it
relied on intuition, and faith, and
imagination. I I was really getting
ready to push back on you and say, "Hey,
that's a lot of what makes science like
modern science great." And and
you you brought that in,
you know, very nicely
um in the later stages of the of the
lecture there.
Kind of
inspired.
Okay. Well, thank you. Yeah. Yeah. Thank
you.
Um
great. A- Any questions?
Okay. That's fine. Okay. So, um I got a
I got a light question. Okay. Great. Um
I I didn't know about Newton's
predictions about the end of the world.
But uh if you're saying 2050, 2060,
what do you think the chances are that
he was right? Okay. Um
Okay.
So, Newton.
Okay. So,
um what do we know that Newton
um
predic- predicted the end of the world.
Okay. The reason why is this.
So, Newton didn't have any family. He
didn't have a wife. He didn't have any
children. Um so, his entire estate was
left to his nephews and his nieces.
And um Newt- and Newton also left him a
lot of money. Okay? These are aris-
aristocrats. Newton is Newton is
actually the first commoner, the first
non-royal in English history to receive
a state funeral. He's the first commoner
to be buried at West- Westminster Abbey,
okay? So, he was a very big deal
um
um back then.
Um and his relatives, obviously, were
aristocrats. But the thing about
aristocrats is that over time, they
become poor.
So, and what do you do when you become
poor? Well, you sell off what is
valuable. And so, Newton's papers
Newton's papers
all his notes
were auctioned off in like I think the
1930s. I I
I don't remember, okay? But 1930s.
And you would imagine that everyone
would want these notes, right? Cuz like
they reveal genius to you. But for
whatever reason, um they didn't really
sell over well. And and
the in the in the sell was so bad, the
auction was so bad that it was sold
piecemeal, okay?
And one person who bought
the notes was um John Keynes, the the
economist, John Keynes, the economist.
And he was so excited to read the papers
of Newton. He was like, "Oh my god,
there must be so much mathematics in
these papers that will lead to new
discoveries, right?" So, when he
actually read the papers, he was
actually aghast at what he discovered.
It was alchemy, it was theology.
And so,
um what
um Newton was trying to do was he was
trying to read the Bible
and look for secret code.
I mean, he was he was crazy, okay? Look
for a secret code within the Bible that
would tell him the future.
He was actually convinced of something
called the second coming.
He was convinced that Jesus will return.
I mean, these are all Christians at this
point, right? He was actually convinced
that
Jesus will return.
And so, he wants to know when he would
return
and how he would return. Okay? So, I So,
I think he made the the prediction 2060.
But I can't I can't be sure. But But he
made a prediction when the world would
end. What's more important for us is
that
he became what we know what we call a
Christian Zionist.
Okay?
The idea of a Christian Zionist, and
this is really important, is that
once you predict the future and you know
when Jesus is returning, you want to
know how he returns.
And Newt- uh became actually convinced
that for Jesus to return, certain
conditions had to be met
in order to facilitate his return.
One major condition was the return of
the Jews to Jerusalem.
Because at this point, um Jerusalem was
being controlled by the Ottomans.
Okay? He was actually convinced that we
had to get all the world's Jews and
return them to Jerusalem. Okay? Only
problem was, Jews didn't want to go
back.
Okay? And so, um Chris- I think Newton,
and this is completely unknown about
him, okay? He's actually one of the
founders of a movement called Christian
Zionism is, let's figure out how to get
all the Jews to go back to Jerusalem,
and this was sort of process
which will culminate with the return of
Jesus.
Okay?
So, that's
um
Newton. Um and so, what this tells us,
okay, and this is also something that
is really important is he was part of a
secret society
with John Locke and some other really
important individuals. And this secret
society,
I mean, like they were considered they
considered themselves the true church.
Right? So, um Newton in his notes, he
was very clear. He thought the Holy
Trinity was nonsense. There's only one
God. Okay? And he was a representative
of God on Earth. He was here on a divine
mission. So, he's part of this secret
society to try to achieve Christian
Zionism and to discover when the second
coming uh will happen. So, he makes this
prediction 2060. So, when So, whether or
not Newton is correct, that's not the
issue. The issue is that with his power,
with his influence, he was heavily
promoting Christian Zionism in England.
And as we know, what will happen is
these people will go to America.
Okay?
A lot of these people who are Christian
Zionists, they will go to America
believing that America is the new
Jerusalem. Well, and then what will
happen
later on is
um the Zionist Christian Zionists will
link up and they will plot to
um bring the Jews back to
uh
Jerusalem. And this And this leads to
something called the Balfour
Declaration.
Right? Which is to say that after World
World I,
when the Ottoman Empire was defeated,
um the British Empire um now gives
permission to all the Jews in the world
to return to Jerusalem, whether or not
they want to.
Okay? So, this is why history is so
important, because you cannot possibly
understand what's happening in the
Middle East today without first
understanding all this history.
Right?
So, does that make sense?
Okay. All right.
Great.
So, odds are he was right. 2060, things
are going to happen. Well, well well I I
again, okay. So, I'm just kidding. I'm
So, 2060, again,
that's not the issue. The issue is that
there are very powerful people in this
world who believe in this and who want
who believe that it is their divine
mission to make this come true. To use
their power, to use their influence, to
use their money to make this prediction
come true.
It's not really a prophecy, okay?
It's really a plan.
This is what it is. It's a plan.
It's like, how do we bring back Jesus?
Because when Jesus returns, the world
ends and everyone's happy. Okay? That's
heaven comes on Earth. But how do we
make it happen? Well, here's the plan.
Christian Zionism.
Right? So, that's that's that's that's
my real concern. Whether or not the
world ends in 2016, I don't know, okay?
But the fact that there are really
powerful people
of the stature of I think Newton with
like almost unlimited resources
and unlimited power, they actually
believe in this and they want to make
this come true. That should be the major
concern.
Right?
Okay. So, I apologize for
for going out on this tangent, okay? But
um so, uh we don't have class on
Thursday, but next Tuesday we'll start
the Age of Exploration, okay?